[Music]
early voting in nevada starts
tomorrow some 1.2 million ballots were
already mailed out statewide
now you can officially take part in this
vital election
today 8 news now reporter kate houston
stopped by an early voting center
mountain crest community center
up in the northwest valley to see what
you need to know
before you head to the polls mountain
crest is one of 48
early voting locations across clark
county many of these early voting
locations are also mail ballot drop-off
sites
early voting will last for 14 days
that's through october 30th
any registered voter in clark county can
vote in person before election day at
any voting site
the clark county elections office is
asking everyone who plans to vote in
person
to be patient and courteous to those
around you in addition to the in-person
voting options
all registered voters were sent a mail
ballot as well
you can return that through the mail or
bring it to any county ballot drop-off
location
today i spoke to some voters who plan to
drop off their ballot as early as
possible
just being part of the process being
part of the process getting my ballot in
here
making sure i'm ahead of time making
sure that i'm doing everything properly
and make my vote count we want to avoid
the crowds
and rather come and drop them off the
clark county elections office tells me
that if you plan to drop off your mail
ballot you do not need to wait in line
it should be a quick process the office
adds that this general election
is the longest ever with more than 70
contests
including five ballot questions voters
are encouraged to visit the clark county
election department website
there's information on all voting
locations how to properly fill out your
ballot and you can even check wait times
due to the pandemic masks and social
distancing are required at all polling
sites
if you don't want to vote early though
on election day 125 voting centers will
be open
and that's on november 3rd reporting
from mountain crest community center
kate houston 8 news now